well I went to the public library back
in 1952 I was around in the 15 years old
new book had come in called giant brains
and machines that think and it's a made
the analogy that these merging computers
could amplify the power of human brain
and I thought if you know computers
could help amplify that unique power it
could be an enormous benefit to mankind
so I got so excited about this I took my
paper route collection money and went to
the hardware store and bought all the
parts to build a computer back then and
I build a computer that played automatic
game of tic-tac-toe in a way that was
initially unbeatable and then people got
frustrated when they were using it so I
made a little counter in the back so
that every 35 move would be a mistake
and then they could occasionally win and
they were much more happy and that you
know was entered into a science fair and
I want a scholarship but to MIT and so
it was really an opportunity for me to
go from just casual interest to really
getting serious about trying to study
the brain and the human nervous system
and how that could allow us to make more
effective intelligent systems when I was
at MIT and in the 50s there the word
neuroscience that hadn't even been
coined none of the precision of
understanding how the brain is operating
existed at that time I was studying a
quantitative biology which meant we
started at the cell level and we're in
the tomb but I killer levels I was using
the tools available at the time to study
what happened during the change in the
brain from a tadpole into frog and to I
had available was just a micropipette
which is a very thin little glass tube
but the finest resolution could only get
me a measurement of hundreds and
hundreds of neurons in the area today we
have single neuron recording devices
where you can actually find out what one
neuron is doing in isolation over the
hunt
billion that exists and then of course
we have these wonderful brain scanning
systems that help by computers which
tell us you know has some cognitive
thought happening what part of the brain
is active under that cognitive thought
and that we can also have additional
devices that tell us not only the exact
location but the exact time when these
transactions are occurring so they give
us brilliant enhanced tools to be able
to understand what's happening in the
cognitive functions in the human brain
what really motivated us to start the
McGovern Institute was the enormity of
the impact of mental illness and brain
disease on society there's a terrible
impact on emotions and quality of life
for people busted enormous economic
impact on society and that's one of the
reasons that we thought the time was
right to move ahead with the McGovern
Institute because if we could make a
significant impact on curing or
preventing these mental illnesses and
brain diseases the quality of life for
people throughout the world would be
enormous we improved we can start
research for which no other source of
funding is available and some of them
are gonna turn into me a major discovery
we don't have any particular scorecards
in mind but we know from the history of
research projects in the history of
initiatives that new science and
technology areas are that if you try 10
you're gonna have one or two that have
enormous leave useful results for
mankind our mission of course was that
help cure mental illness and brain
disease but there were consequences far
beyond those which we had never
anticipated what I think the Bible says
the person who gives often gets more
rewards than the person who receives the
gift and I think that insight is very
true that the giver gets tremendous
unexpected rewards in terms of a sense
of a much better quality of life than
they had before they made their
philanthropic commitment this is the
most exciting time in their our science
I think we're five to ten years away
from major breakthroughs though that
will prevent or cure schizophrenia and
Alzheimer's attention deficit disorder
or autism dyslexia etc and
so now's the time to be involved because
when those discoveries come about you
know you can take great pride in the
contribution that you made to making it
happen